hey guys what is going on welcome to
another Python tutorial video this video
we're going to be talking about how we
can convert Python to scripts to Python
3 scripts I had no idea about this I
actually just kind of stumbled on it not
too long ago but there's actually built
in module that comes with Python 3
installations and it's called 2 to 3 and
what it's going to do is it's going to
run through your Python 2 script and
convert it to Python 3 and I use this on
extremely large scripts and it I'm
trying to think all the only thing the
only thing it didn't do very well on was
the H Mac module which is for like
encryption and stuff so you're not using
that then you're probably more than fine
but I've been really impressed with the
converting ability of 2 to 3 I mean it
does it well so anyway I'm going to show
you guys how to use it first I'll show
you guys on Windows I think most people
that watch my videos are actually using
Windows but I will show you on a Linux
machines wall just in case someone is
curious how it works but anyway we have
a URL Lib too and we've got a bunch of
Python 2.7 code going on here obviously
this won't run in Python 3 and we've got
you know first of all there is no your
lip 2 in Python 3 this isn't the proper
syntax in 3 you can't do this at print
function in 3 this is improper syntax
for try and except it should be true
except exception comma E and again you
can't print print like this it's a print
function so I try to throw in a healthy
a short enough script that everybody
could test it while at the same time not
too long and be crazy so if you happen
to have your own Python 2 script use it
or if you want pause the video type out
this script or just type out a print
high or something like that just to get
a feel for it so anyways let's do it so
the name of this file I have placed
these files on my desktop I've got 2 to
3 me and then within it we've got Python
2 ugliness and that is this file that
we're looking at
right here so to use two to three
depending on what machine you're on you
might have to type things differently
but I'll just hang hang in there and
I'll try to hold your hand so we'll
close out of this and what you'll do to
open up a command line to whatever
folder you're in just like go to the
folder hold shift right click open
command window here if you're on Windows
and now you're ready to type in the
command and the command for 2 to 3 is
going to be the following first you have
to reference Python if you're on Windows
and python is in your path as in python
34 not python 27 or whatever version of
2 you might have although I'm not quite
sure what you're running this if you are
not using python 3 but sometimes python
2 is in your path before python 3 and it
chooses that so if this does not work
for example you should go type python
hit enter and it should be Python 3.4 3
in some version of 3 if it's not you
better type the full path if you can't
type this and you get like an error
pythons not recognized then you need to
type the full path to python well I
cannot get out of this interesting I
thought it ctrl C or control D would do
it anyway if you got out or if you typed
Python in your stuck open it up again
otherwise to reference Python give the
full path so C colon slash Python 34
slash Python and actually I think the p
and python is capitalized them yeah so
it's actually capital P Python but then
the other one will be lowercase so
Python forty four slash Python you might
also want to reference it as Python exe
or just straight-up Python it doesn't
matter anyway here's the syntax so first
what you can do is you can just say
Python and then you sometimes you might
be able to get away with a like two to
three and then Python to ugliness dot pi
something like that right but it is
saying that it doesn't exist on Linux
you again might be able to get away with
that but for the most Windows users
you'll have to type this so Python and
you might have to specify the full path
model then you specify the path to 2 to
3 the path is going to be C colon slash
Python 34a / tools / and actually tools
as a capital T tools and then / scripts
/ - 2 3 . PI ok so you're calling that
script and now we're going to pass as a
sort of parameter to that script if you
remember I showed you guys a long time
ago how you could pass parameters to
Python scripts through the command line
that's what's about to happen here we're
going to pass a parameter through and
the parameter is going to be the script
itself so python 2 ugliness dot pi now
hit enter hopefully this will run so i
was long to type okay so here it
basically tells us everything that we
want it we would might want to change
about the script so here it you know
suggests renaming which is the exact
same name then it suggests well we would
get rid of URL Lib to replace that with
import URL Lib dot request URL Lib error
and URL Lib dot parse try we would
retain but we would get rid of this your
Lib to that you were all open replace it
with URL Lib dot request URL open and so
on we would get rid of print X and use
the proper and then we would get rid of
um accept exception did I I think I'm
must have mistyped my version of
exception let me go back to that script
real quick except exception as e
sometimes I guess I confused myself but
accept exception comma E is the Python
2.7 syntax sorry about that we replace
that let me draw that one more time
let's just run that again so here you
can see that it catches the error right
except exception comma T needs to be
replaced with except exception as a
print string and then the function for
print and all of that so then it also
says what you need to modify now that's
all fine and dandy but it didn't
actually modify our script so how might
we actually get it to modify the script
uh we can just throw in a dash a dash W
basically
so we'll just hit the up arrow here and
where we call the script we're going to
pass one more command but before the
actual script that we call right so
after two to three PI do space - W
that's it and that's four right and
basically it's going to change our file
it's going to write to our file itself
so it does that now we'll go to that
folder here two to three me and you
should have a backup slow dot back just
means backup so this is the old file
right the old one that was replaced and
then we have the new one that was just
written so edit that and you see it has
the new code to it and this is now
Python 3 code so hopefully we can all
save and run that and ensure enough it
does indeed print out the code so that's
it with two to three now we'll just show
you guys in Linux as well but Linux will
be basically the exact same thing you're
going to just reference you know two to
three so you might have to give the full
path two to three but in many cases you
can just say two to three so anyways if
you're on Windows you can pretty much
stop here if you're on Linux I will just
show it anyways so let's do that now all
right so in Linux uh here I'm just on a
Raspberry Pi so into let's go ahead and
CD into a desktop apparently I don't
know might be there yeah why can't we
there we go um and now let's just do
sudo nano
hi to scripts hi and I just copy and
pasted or copied that other script that
we had and import URL into okay so
obviously our indents didn't stick try
that try statement can stay print X
except exception okay so I should work
we can exit there save yes so here I
have two versions of Python so we've got
Python installed so we can run basically
two point seven point three
alternatively we can also run Python
three that so we have both versions of
Python here so I could run Python
um and then snake that script I think
was like PI to something right so we can
run that and onion is like some stupid
indent issues hold on let's go back oh
maybe it's the exception causes cause
that one hopefully that's a let's try
this one more let's just check it again
okay so that printed it out so obviously
it's working in Python - but Python 3 PI
2 to scripts isn't going to run write a
syntax error so now you can do on most
devices you'll be able to just say two
to three like that and then you could
say 2 to 3 PI to script let's see if we
can get away with it and write so it's
just going to go straight into it and
take its time apparently sorry this is
not a PI and the PI is actually working
right now yes but that's why the codes
going so slow but anyway um so you can
do that and then also obviously you can
write so 2 - 3 - right PI script up hi
oh wait root go little pod go little PI
that could as I like to say okay so it
modified it again let's do LS here and
you can see here is our backup so it's
still there and now we can do Python 3
PI 2 script PI run that and as you can
see it worked
so anyways um that's it just wanted to
show you PI 2 or 2 to 3 again I had no
idea that even existed so
congratulations if you knew but I just
happened to stumble on it and I wish
that someone had pointed this out to me
a long time ago I've spent many hours
converting scripts and this could have
been much easier so anyway hopefully you
guys enjoyed if you have any questions
or comments leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time